hey it's been a while since we heard
from furious trumpets Jimmy from Philly
I know some people in the audience love
hearing from Jimmy from Philly some
people in the audience have said David
please no more Jimmy from Philly we
don't want to hear it at all we have
heard from Jimmy from Philly and he is
furious at soy boy sycophants and
continues to seem to misunderstand how
some online social platforms work take a
listen to this
David Jimmy from Philly right yeah I
just got banned on Facebook because one
of your little toy boy sycophants rich
Louis reported me to Facebook right what
a joke Trump 2020 because you again
listen we don't even have moderators on
Facebook we don't we don't we don't
touch Facebook at all so as usual if
Jimmy is getting banned from these
platforms it's because Facebook is
determining that he's violating some
kind of community standards and when you
hear the mouth on this guy does it shock
anybody to think that what he's posting
to social media might realistically get
people banned or blocked from these
platforms Jimmy I'm sorry we haven't had
a chance to speak live during live calls
but it's good to hear from you in a
sense and still very very furious we've
got a great bonus show for you today we
are going to talk about the Cleveland
Police officer who urinated on a girl as
she waited for the bus he has been
sentenced to four and a half years in
prison we will also talk about China's
birth rate hitting the lowest in modern
history this is an interesting economic
story it's an interesting political
story the China birth rate story
actually relates to a lot of different
issues that are important if you're just
an observer of what's going on in the
world also Tulsi Gabbard has endorsed
legalizing drugs we will discuss all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
two ways to get instant access become a
member at join pakman.com or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show we'll speak to you then